lise effectivement nous sommes ici sur
le plateau de la voy libre avec quatre
invités Jérôme Durin pour le PS Philippe
Hervieux pour Europe Écologie Les Verts
Alain sugnau pour l'UMP Édouard Ferrand
pour le Front national j'avais promis de
vous donner la parole Jérôme Durin sur
sur le front national avec notamment une
question je vous la pose puisque notre
internaute nous demande de la poser Marc
pourquoi plus personne ne dit que le FN
est un parti d'extrême
droite parce que je je pense qu'on a on
a on a pris conscience à raison que les
Français sont grand major et vaccin
c'est pas en leur disant c'est pas bien
de voter pour le FN qui vont changer de
de posture et de vote il y a deux choses
qui font voter pour le Front national
une exaspération par rapport à la
situation économique et sociale les fin
de mois sont dures la vraie insécurité
la vraie insécurité c'est une insécurité
sociale les gens qui qui ont plus
d'argent qui s'inquiètent pour eux-même
pour leurs enfants et la deuxième raison
c'est la question des pratiques
politiques on fait le reproche on a
parfois raison à une classe politique
d'avoir eu des des pratiques archaïques
ou d'avoir encore des pratiques
archaïques moi je pense qu'il faut
travailler vraiment sur ce sujet
davantage de transparence davantage de
sobriété aller vers le non cumu et et la
solution elle vient pas du Front
national quand on voit que Monsieur
Ferrand il est eurodéputé dans le
Sud-Ouest et conseill régional en
Bourgogne à quoi ça ressemble la
candidate dans le dou elle é elle était
même pas élu dans la
circonscription les attaques
personnelles c'est trop facile vous
répondrez répondre cumule
ai vous allez répondre
allez c'est l' gauche c'est l'elle
gauche du PS qui parle et de toute façon
c'est un élu de la République a le droit
de parler laissez-moi parler bien s par
a quand on parle de non cumulle par
exemple on voit que le Front national en
avait fait un thème mes collègues
sénateurs ravier de Marseille ou
Racheline de Toulon ben il continu donc
les le Front national ne changera pas
les choses sur les pratiques ce que je
vois par exemple puisqu'on parle des
départemental c'est que entre 2004
l'herbe au monde en sonedoir et
aujourd'hui les crédits de cabinet du
conseil général ont été divisés par 5 ça
c'est de la sobriété c'est de la
transparence c'est
ch voilà il me semble que il faut aussi
que chacun fasse le ménage devant sa
porte et le Front national en l'espèce
n'est pas vertueux sur ces sujets alors
pas de pas vertueux je vous laisse
répondre quand même monsieur Ferran
finalement vous vous faites vous
pratiquez la politique comme les autres
ex c'est ce que dit Monsieur moi je suis
ravi parce que ce matin je vois du petit
lait le débat tourne autour du Front
national c'est vrai que le Front
National est aujourd'hui la vraie force
populaire la vra la vraie force
populaire nationale et sociale et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les Français ont
ouvert les yeux ils ont ouvert les yeux
notamment avec l'élection dans le dou on
a vu que le Front national aujourd'hui
pouvait être un parti qui qui est en
mesure de gagner des élections sans
avoir besoin du scrutin prop revenons
aux élection justement est-ce que
finalement qu'est-ce que vous en espérez
parce que vous ne pensez pas prendre des
conseils départementaux je pense mais
est-ce que vous espérez des des accords
avec les uns et les autres pour essayer
de gérer comme ça a été le cas à la
région il y a une certaine époque alors
d'abord sur le plan national il y a
plusieurs départements où nous pouvons
prendre enfin plusieurs départements où
le frond national peut gagner notamment
je pense à à looise ou au Cluse je pense
que aujourd'hui C ces élections vont
montrer que nous sommes bien impantés
que le frond national est une une force
majeure ici en Bourgogne dans Lyon nous
avons au moins trois ou quatre cantons
gagnables hein c'est c'est très
important puisque mais qu'est-ce que
vous en ferez finalement et bien nous
allons être fort justement pour pour
montrer que nous avons des élus qui sont
capables de pouvoir s'investir dans dans
dans les départements montrer que le
frond national a une autre vision que
cette politique UMPS qu'on nous a
présenté depuis 40 ans et le Front
national va aujourd'hui montrer que et
bien il va pouvoir justement entrer dans
les exécutifs et je pense que c'est
important parce que ça va préparer les
élections de fin d'année qui sert les
élections régionales il y a un grand
renouveau il y a un renouveau
aujourd'hui de la vie politique qui est
en train de de se mettre en marche le
Front national aujourd'hui va avoir des
élus je pense en en sonéloire dans
Lyonne et et certainement aussi dans la
Nièvre alin sugn finalement est-ce que
le plus grand enjeu il vient pas de de
votre droite j'allais dire euh pour ces
élections est-ce que ça ne va pas
émietter vos vos propres voix
és quand on parle de de la progression
du Front national faudrait remercier je
pense que Monsieur Ferrand doit le faire
tous les jours madame tobira
effectivement c'est quand on a ce type
de politique on parlait de l'insécurité
tout à l'heure que par essence on
renflou bien sûr les troupes du front
national et euh c'est le débat tout à
l'heure UMPS aujourd'hui c'est plutôt
psfn si on regarde bien puisque les deux
sont liés euh al je dis pas que les
intérêts sont communs mais le meilleur
moyen d'empêcher une alternance en
France c'est continuer à provoquer la
Hire de nos concitoyens on a parlé tout
à l'heure y compris de certains droits
d'asile dans des zones rurales il est
certain que c'est pas le meilleur moyen
de faire que on arrive à des votes plus
républicains je pense que si on agite
les chiffons rouges on sait ce qui se
passe et Madame tobira d'ailleurs est
très absente aujourd'hui du débat on
s'est rendu compte qu'on l'a caché un
petit peu n'empêche que son son son
esprit est toujours là et que dans ces
condition de concitoyens le le sent bien
donc je pense que le vrai moyen si on
veut vraiment lutter contre le Front
national c'est pas de tenir des discours
compris ici devant les médias c'est
vraiment d'avoir une vraie politique et
d'avoir une politique qui permett aux
Français et aux Français de se dire on
s'occupe de nous et les politiques
essaie de mettre en place des textes qui
permettront d'éviter les difficultés du
temps le reste c'est probablement
simplement un discours et ce que je
regrette aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a
rien de concret donc c'est valable dans
ma famille politique je crois queil faut
aussi considérer que on n pas fait tout
bien mais c'est en tous les cas
l'occasion aujourd'hui de proposer
vraiment un projet alternatif pour la
France et ça passe également par les
élections cantonales parce que élection
despart ça compte ça d'avoir des
majorités dans les départements j'espère
d'ailleurs qu'on en gagnera quelquesuns
et je pense que c'est ce qui risque
d'arriver simplement si bien évidemment
le jeu démocratique n'est pas faussé par
des provocations qui aboutissent à des
votes qui par essence feront que l'UMP
ne pourra pas dans ces conditions gagner
des présidences alors que c'est bien sûr
l'enjeu si on veut sur les territoires
répondre présent avec une réforme à
l'échelle du nation l'UMP avec l'UDI
l'UMP avec ses alliés avec toutes celles
et T ceux je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent que les électeurs sont toujours
souverain avec toutes celles et tous
ceux qui voudront aujourd'hui qui
appelle la voté socialiste qui voudront
dans ces conditions al c'est la raison
pour laquelle je crois qu'on peut pas
non plus mélanger les genres he c'est
pas simplement les partis politiques
c'est effectivement les projets des
partis politiques qui vont compter
demain alors on a beaucoup parlé du
Front national mais on va aussi parler
de d'Europe Écologie Les ver parce que
la position est un peu compliquée à
comprendre peut-être pour certains
électeurs notamment en Bourgogne on voit
par exemple dans Lyonne une Chantal
doucar qui est élu à la région qui
travaille avec les socialistes qui doit
son siège quelque part aux accords avec
les socialistes et qui là euh signe un
accord avec le Front de Gauche dans
Lyonne on a du mal à saisir que se
passe-t-il comment l'expliquer aux
électeurs ben c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'estàd queon a
des situations vous savez l'écologie
elle avance pas à la même vitesse qu'on
soit sur un territoire rural qu'on soit
dans un quartier ou qu'on soit dans une
ville donc et et ça dépend aussi des
populations qui sont là et cetera donc
nous on a décidé pour ces élections
d'avoir une politique de subsidiarité de
laisser faire en fait les groupes locaux
pour que eux-mêmes en fonction des
conditions de leur territoire euh euh
bah nous disent comment euh ils compte
faire avancer l'écologie alors du coup
ça donne euh des alliances parfois avec
le Front de gauche vous avez cité ce cas
de Lyonne mais ça donne aussi des
alliances avec le Parti socialiste ici à
Dijon où sur les cantons dijeuné on
considère que bah la politique
concernant l'écologie les politiques sur
les rues piétonnes sur les espaces verts
sur euh euh le tram sur la mobilité euh
et cetera sont des bonnes politiques qui
font avancer l'écologie euh la mise en
place des deux ininérateurs bio masse et
cetera font que on considère que ça va
dans le bon sens donc on veut aller
continuer à amplifier cette cette
dynamique c'est donc une politique un
petit peu effectivement différencié sur
sur les territoires mais nous on
comprend enfin la logique c'est celle-là
faire avancer l'écologie comme elle se
présente trouver le CRAN suivant en
fonction du territoire c'est bien
accepté ça du côté socialiste monsieur
Durin oui je suis pas certain que ce
soit si vertueux que ça la fin parce que
le but de de ces élections
départementales le but de ces élections
départemental c'est donner des majorités
pour gérer des départements moi je je je
crois pas que les que les nos
concitoyens attendent de faire avancer
tel ou telle idée ils veulent savoir
pourquoi on s'engage nous en sonir on a
une majorité départementale qui a un
bilan qui a un projet partout avec des
cantons qui seront représentés si on
gagne par des des candidats de la
majorité on couvre l'ensemble du
territoire donc on s'engage sur des
objectifs de gestion départementale le
sujet c'est pas de de prendre appui sur
une élection pour faire avancer des
idées euh national générique c'est de de
dire ce qu'on va faire pour nos
territoires on parlait de fracture
territoriale tout à l'heure on parle là
de haut débit on parle de déplacement on
parle de politique sociale on parle de
des personnes âgées c'est ça le sujet
des départemental c'est pas des des
idées nationales alors justement bah je
vais vous laisser on a 3 minutes à peu
près pour conclure cette émission chacun
un petit mot de je sais pas 45 secondes
sur vos objectifs euh et notamment sur
la campagne électorale il y a une
question de Pascal est-ce qu'il va y
avoir des meetings cette année peut-être
que vous pouvez en toucher un mot euh
Édouard Ferrand alors qu'est-ce que vous
voulez vraiment pour ces élections
départementales en Bourgogne c'est
gagner quelques cantons pour entrer dans
les conseils généraux c'est ça
départementaux pardon et bien nous avons
reçu euh FL Florian Philippo le le 25
janvier à osser et la semaine prochaine
nous aurons Marion maréchal le peen Le
Pen à Saint-Florentin donc le le jeudi
19 à 18h euh voilà les nos grands
leaders nationaux sont sont venus en en
Bourgogne demain nous aurons Marine Le
Pen à à Bran en en sonéir je crois que
la Bourgogne fait partie des objectifs
du Front national c'est-à-dire un
renouveau de du personnel politique nous
aurons nous serons le seul parti
politique à avoir des candidats partout
partout les les couleurs du
rassemblement bleu marine seront IC haut
et fort et je pense que nous avons des
candidats de très grande qualité nous
avons montré que nous avions aussi des
des solutions des solutions pour en
finir avec l'umplps qui aujourd'hui
malheureusement n'ont pas permis le vrai
développement et le développement
surtout culturel de cette belle
Bourgogne philipux un mot vous n'êtes ni
um ni PS alors quels objectifs bah
écoutez nous les objectifs c'est
évidemment de faire le meilleure score
possible là où on est en autonome et
puis d'apporter au deuxème tour ben
notre appui au candidat évidemment
contrairement à ce que disait Jérôme
Durin tout à l'heure c'est pas faire
avancer des grandes idées nationales qui
nous intéresse c'est concrètement quel
va être le plan déchet du département
concrètement quel va être comment régler
les questions de mob
comment régler les problèmes de
biodiversité sur les territoires c'est
ça qui nous intéresse alors
effectivement c'est transversal ça
reprend pas exactement le découpage
politique du paysage politique français
n'empêche que nous c'est ce qui nous
intéresse parce qu'on se considère que
c'est ce qui est bon pour la planète et
bon pour l'environnement et bon pour les
hommes donc voilà quel est notre
objectif pour ces départemental alin Sun
en quelques mots la droite est confiante
en côe d'or dans Lyonne pour conserver
ses basons et en gagner d'autres très
bon candidat je pense qu'on va gagner un
certain nombre de cantons on a de bons
candidat je vois dans le sud de la Côte
d'Or je crois queon a réussi à faire oui
avec de nouveaux candidats surtout hein
des nouveaux qui sont là effectivement
pour défendre un territoire puis
également une idée et puis bien sûr
quelques leaders Nicolas Sarkozi sera
jeudi prochain à Charles surs à 16h45 je
reçois moi Henry Guenot juste après à
19h30 porte-marie de brourgogne à Baon
ça une voie Gauliste je crois qu'on a
besoin aujourd'hui un petit peu de ce
message pour sortir un peu justement du
Patos dont on parle tous et puis Laurent
Bouquier là dit à Dijon au soutien de
Laurent bourginia je crois qu' dit 18h30
donc la campagne est engagée chez vous
aussi oui oui bien sûr la campagne est
engagée pas de meeting pas de grand
meeting prévu je crois qu'on est engagé
dans un travail de terrain on a fait un
lancement de campagne il a il y a 15
jours on a eu une belle affluence avec
une belle dynamique je crois que
l'élection dans le dou a remobilisé
notre notre
électorat il y il y a quelque chose qui
se joue autour de la démocratie autour
de l'attachement à à l'unité
républicaine donc je je pense que on va
porter ce thème là et puis on va
travailler sur des thèmes de terrain les
places dans les pad combien à quel tarif
on peut offrir ça aux familles le
numérique dans tous les territoires la
RCEA pour ce qui concerne le département
voilà les collégiens leurs conditions de
travail des sujets concrets merci merci
merci à tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez voir ou revoir cette émission sur
notre site internet
bourgon.france3.fr la semaine prochaine
et bien nous commencerons le premier des
quatre débats que nous consacrerons aux
quatre départements de la région d'ici
les élections et nous commencerons par
la Nièvre ce sera donc samedi prochain
et attention l'émission commence sera
dès 11h d'ici là c'est le 1213 qui se
poursuit tout de suite à bientôt merci
de votre attention